all right welcome to the live stream a
lot to talk about today have kind of an
interesting announcement to make but I'm
gonna wait a little bit and do that
later when more people are on we'll take
your questions we'll talk about a bunch
of different stuff and we'll sort of
catch up on on the insanity that's been
going on I I'm getting more and more
people emailing me and saying David you
know how long can this go on Rex
Tillerson Trump Secretary of State
called him a [ __ ] and Trump showed up
in Puerto Rico and he insulted Puerto
Ricans and he shot paper towel rolls
like basketballs and has still
accomplished nothing legislatively that
this can't really go on that much longer
right and sadly you know I think that we
have to be realistic and realize that it
can go on for a long time it can and it
probably will go on for a long time
because when you look at Trump's
approval rating he's still hovering
between that 35 and 38 percent mark and
that is not low enough that Republicans
are gonna jump ship and say it's time to
take down Trump because this is a
disaster for everybody right and though
it's really at least until the 2018
election at which point maybe Democrats
could take over either the house or the
Senate although by no means guaranteed
until that point there's zero chance
that with a 35 to 38 percent approval
rating or even bumping up to 39 or 40
percent for Donald Trump that
Republicans would move to get him out
I've said before that if Donald Trump's
approval rating did didn't drop into the
high 20s and maybe stayed there at that
point depending on what the internals
are and how many Republicans disapprove
of the job Trump is doing maybe you
would see Republicans merely for
self-preservation not before any moral
duty but because of self-preservation
they might say hey Trump's approval
rating is going to start hurting my
reelection chances unless I get out and
denounce what's going on but that's not
happening right there is it is
abundantly clear that we have like we
did under the George W Bush
administration but realistically it's
even more stunning because Ron
is so much more incompetent than george
w bush which sounds crazy to say we have
a percentage of ideologically committed
trumpets that are going to stick with
him period right it is they're going to
stick with him . so i think it's
important that we all think about the
best way to be activists with Trump in
the White House and it's not all bad I
mean I've said this before Trump in the
White House might be better for
progressives than Trump out and pence in
the White House for example then pence
and Trump out and Paul Ryan taking over
I mean all of these scenarios are
arguably worse for progressives because
with Trump in the White House with
constant scandal still the Russian
investigations are continuing and every
week we actually learn more right the
best scenario for progressives might
actually be Trump stays in
scandal-ridden ridden until 2020
Democrats take over I don't know the
Senate or House in 2018 and then take
over the other one House or Senate in
2020 along with the presidency that
might actually be the best hope because
if if you do have a trump impeachment or
resignation you will very quickly get
rid of the sort of cartoonish stuff that
we're seeing under Trump and Mike Pence
an ideological right-wing religious
right winger will immediately
immediately start to make things happen
for Republicans so that is I think a
concern that we all have to think about
and we're going to talk about it
more during the livestream and if this
is your first live stream welcome these
are actually live unless you're watching
a replay two ways to submit questions or
comments which will be read and I'll
answer your questions or react to your
comments
number one is using super chat super
chat is on it's the dollar sign at the
bottom of the chat window within YouTube
now YouTube takes 30% of those super
chat dollars so you can
invent that there's a link in the
description for the for the livestream
by going to stream labs.com slash the
david pakman show and if you do that you
will be able to also make a contribution
ask a question make a comment I will
read it I will react to it but you will
circumvent the 30% that YouTube takes I
think it's just like 2.9 percent plus 30
cents or something that stream labs
takes new members and patrons who sign
up during the live stream I will
personally thank you and sing your
praises so please do that very very
exciting stuff that is how the program
is funded that's how we distribute the
200 radio and TV stations around the
country david pakman.com slash
membership and patreon.com slash david
pakman show and related to this I do
have what I think is a very exciting
announcement related to the long-form
lectures that I've been doing at Boston
College and the possibility of putting
those on the Internet I will I will get
to that a little bit later in the stream
and lastly please don't troll obvious
trolling and hate will get you banned
subtle trolling probably won't if it is
subtle enough and the subtlety barometer
is mostly up to the moderators who I
have deputized to implement enforce I
guess the no obvious trolling and hate
so ok will there be repercussions to
this Porto Rico disaster if you didn't
see there's a clip up on our YouTube
channel now from today's broadcast show
Donald Trump showed up in Puerto Rico
after having insulted not only the mayor
of San Juan but also Puerto Ricans in
general is wanting everything handed to
them in hurricane recovery and Trump
showed up and he did a press conference
he's got the I believe it was the mayor
of San Juan somewhere off to his left
Melania to his immediate left and the
governor of Puerto Rico to his right and
Trump scolded Puerto Ricans for forcing
the United States to spend money on them
said it's fortunately not a real
disaster like Katrina and congratulated
it's weird to say congratulate but
congratulated the Governor of Puerto
Rico for the fact that
I'm only 16 people had been confirmed
dead of course that number has since
more than doubled and maybe increased
even more so absolute and total atrocity
I mean an abortion of a presidential
visit and at some point we just have to
start wondering really two things one is
this just sheer stupidity right is it
more than just Trump's 71 years of life
having been lived as with a philosophy
of greed and self aggrandizement and
self enrichment sort of as the number
one value that could really alter you
and in addition to that we also have to
wonder whether Trump is just genuinely a
bad person and I think all of these are
very legitimate questions and the Puerto
Rico trip has only raised more of them
because no matter how insensitive a
human being Trump could be at this point
his staff knows what happens when Trump
is allowed to speak publicly if it was
possible to control it somebody would
have Trump under control by now so I'm
increasingly leaning in the directions
of early signs of dementia permanent
sleep deprivation
Trump is bragged for decades about only
sleeping four hours a night could be a
lie but if it's true there could be a
persistent state of sleep deprivation
that mimics signs of dementia and he
also just could be genuinely a bad
person and thinks it's just kind of
funny to show up at these things and say
whatever and and and there's no
repercussions ever right so that that's
another factor people have asked me do I
think that Trump has early onset
Alzheimer's number one I don't know if
it's early onset when you're 71 but I'm
not a doctor right I can't I can't
analyze that but we did a big report
that went quite viral 12 13 or 14
million views between YouTube and
Facebook about the signs according to
medical experts that Trump is exhibiting
and I think that there are possibilities
he could just genuinely be a terrible
person he could be completely
sleep-deprived I don't know could be
some combination of all three of these
right okay let me get to a couple of the
questions that are coming in first of
all via super chat Katie Rice sent a $2
Super chat unrelated but how do you feel
about the necro
I have no idea what necro card is necro
card anyone for sex after death
I guess the concept of a necro card is
if you are open to someone I don't even
know what the what the term would be but
if you're open to intercourse after
you've died it looks like you can sign
up for a necro card and then this
basically says I'm authorizing I don't
know who if it's specific or not when I
die someone to have sex with me
that seems pretty whacked seems
absolutely and completely whacked to me
Katie Darrel Dudley sent a five-dollar
super chat when do you think molars
investigation will really come out
before 2020 and he just resigns or
doesn't run again listen I've made it so
let's talk about Russia a little bit
because I see there's the super chat
question there's people in the chat
asking about this or that other person
is H a goodman a russian shill is this
or that person a Russian shell or denier
or whatever here's what's going on with
Russia now I've been making an effort
because of your requests there have been
people in the audience who have said
David Rush is important but try to
condense the Russia's stories into fewer
segments and talk about more other stuff
and I've done that right because the
show is for you right why am I going to
insist on denying the audience what it
is that they want so we've compressed
and condensed Russia coverage where
we're doing a couple stories a week as
opposed to everyday stories and
summarizing what's going on some people
think that because Russia has faded into
the background of the news cycle because
of the hurricanes and the Puerto Rico
disaster and tax cuts in North Korea and
all this other stuff that the Russia
story is gone could not be further from
that number one with every week more and
more of that Christopher Steele Russian
blackmail dossier is confirmed as true
ok that's first and foremost
number two no major russia allegations
have been proven false so far there are
as yet unproven russia allegations but
with time more and more assertions and
allegations are proven to be true right
so the russia story is not going away we
have heard from senator dick Blumenthal
from connecticut who would know because
i mean he's on the Senate Judiciary
Committee
that indictments our forthcoming 99% he
believes for both Michael Flynn and Paul
Manafort Trump's former national
security adviser and former campaign
chairman and manager and even if that
happens here's the thing it was I
believe close to two years from the
first indictment until Richard Nixon
resigned in Watergate during the 1970s
so that's it
right I mean it could be a very long
time and I mentioned this on the program
earlier this week I am generally pretty
cynical and skeptical that justice will
ever be served by any American
institution but for some reason I have
this kind of cautious optimism and maybe
it's just naive it's a right but but
generally that's not my thing what I'm
considering a cautious optimism that
Robert Muller the special prosecutor
will ultimately get to the bottom of it
and all will be known I don't know why I
think that and maybe it's just wishful
thinking and when I say we will know the
ultimate truth of what happened I don't
mean necessarily that people will be
indicted and Trump will be forced to
resign or impeached or whatever I just
mean I want to know what happened and
for whatever reason call me call me
naive bushy-tailed and wide-eyed I am
sort of cautiously optimistic that
that's going to happen nameless King has
sent me a $2 super chat how do you
remain so calm and content well I don't
know where you're getting the idea that
I am so calm and content but if you mean
my on-air demeanor I think it's just
being desensitized to be perfectly
honest I mean after all the interviews
with absolutely insane extremists I
rarely hear something that is shocking I
guess is what I'm saying so I guess
that's why I've become desensitized it's
really nothing to brag about
unfortunately it's good it's kind of sad
in a way but it will it can happen to
all of us it can happen to all of us and
I think that that is uh yeah I don't
know that's it's sad it's a sad reality
over at stream labs.com slash the david
pakman show that's the other place where
you can make contributions to the show
with a question or comment christina has
made a $2.00 contribution
christina has a really good and
interesting question what is your
opinion of state lottery and scratch
tickets also what would you do if you
came into a large sum of money such as a
lottery win very good Christina asks
really good questions so first of all
what's my opinion of state lottery and
scratch tickets from a state revenue
point of view it's a great way for the
state to raise a ton of money so okay if
that money is then used to better the
Commons or used for the benefit of all
then that's a really good thing and I
agree with that the problem with scratch
tickets is they disproportionately are
purchased by people who are least in
financial situations where they should
be playing scratch tickets
I don't really know people who are
well-off financially with very few
exceptions who regularly are playing
scratch tickets or even Powerball I mean
sometimes when the Powerball jackpot is
in the hundreds of millions of dollars
more people I know will just get it
whatever it is a dollar ticket or a $5
ticket how you can tell I have no clue
how much it is because I've never bought
one and that's you know you're kind of
sharing in some public events that
everybody's aware of and is receiving
news coverage but I've only ever seen
scratch tickets be by and large
destructive and at most a small loss
sort of entertainment loss for people
who don't seem to have a gambling
problem so I'm very concerned whenever
anybody tells me that they're regularly
buying scratch tickets I think it not
necessarily targets but appeals to
people who are already probably should
should be saving that money now if I
came into a large sum of money like a
lottery win I don't know that I would be
doing anything that differently I mean I
think I would put a lot of the money
into the program to really like bulking
up our staff and improving the program
and you know putting a lot of money into
YouTube and Facebook ads to be able to
organically or not organically through
paid placement just really grow the
audience and then you know I'd travel
more and I would probably invest in some
real estate
maybe both personally and from from a
sort of real estate
[Music]
investment perspective not landlord type
invest in real estate and and rented
maybe develop a rental real estate
business but I wouldn't really do
anything that crazy or that different I
think it would it would you know huge
sum of money it would certainly impact
my life in that it would change my
financial circumstances in terms of
having to worry about money but I'd
probably keep hosting the show maybe
just from different and and exotic
locations one week from one week to the
next but I I it's you know I'm sort of
unsure how to answer because I don't
even really think about it I don't play
the lottery and I don't really
hypothesize too much about what would I
do if I were to come into a some huge
sum of money yeah so those are some
thoughts all right let me make what I
think is gonna be a very interesting
announcement to a bunch of people here
we announced this on the broadcast
program today but unless you've listened
to the whole show or as a member or on
our radio affiliates you wouldn't know
about this because the YouTube clip has
not yet gone live quick background I
have been teaching a course at Boston
College here in the Boston area as an
adjunct professor and it's a
communication class and it has a lot of
different components but a big aspect of
the class is epistemology how do we know
what we know critical thinking media
literacy logical fallacies biases
understanding understanding filter
bubbles and echo chambers and how all of
that stuff works so every day that I
have a class I'm doing like a sixty to
seventy-five minute lecture on these
subjects with slides and clips and all
sorts of stuff and I started getting
some suggestions from people in our
audience hey David why not make those
available to everybody why not record
the classes and make them available to
everybody well I didn't want because
it's my first time teaching at the
college level
I didn't really feel comfortable
recording the lectures because I feel
like this is not going to be my best my
best go around because you're going to
improve it something
you've done it the first time there's
probably significant improvement I would
guess the second and third time that you
do it but I said maybe we could recreate
those lectures I could sort of read give
those lectures standing in front right
in front of a whiteboard or maybe in the
studio or maybe just here and and mix
them in with the slides and really edit
them together nicely I propose this sort
of just offhandedly and the response has
been stunning I mean just unbelievable
response from people who are adjunct
professors at other schools and said
David if I had the tech capabilities
that you have I would love to be doing
this you should definitely do it and put
those lectures online from people who
have never gone to college who said I
would be thrilled I would consider it a
privilege to be able to observe what the
college class that you teach is like and
then from other people who are just
interested in the subject matter media
literacy and critical thinking and
epistemology so I've been sort of having
internal discussions with our team about
these possibilities and talking to a
couple of video editors and sort of
assessing the amount of work that this
would be to put together an entire
semester of lectures and we've decided
that we're going to do it but we're
going to do it and tie this into a
fundraising goal and this relates sort
of big picture - we really with the
third quarter just ended the third
quarter of 2017 and we are really still
being hit incredibly hard incredibly
hard by the YouTube advertiser boycott
and this started on March 31st or
basically we noticed it two days later
on April 2nd of this year and because of
YouTube's D monetization of anything
that they consider to be remotely
controversial content we have lost about
eighty-five percent of our YouTube
revenue and that's revenue that we did
depend on we did and do depend on thanks
Casper by the way for the contribution I
wanted to make sure you saw your zombie
animation we do depend on that revenue
for funding the show and 85% of it is
gone ok so one thing we've done is
launched a patreon page and stunningly I
mean flatteringly we have surpassed
1,900 individual contributors now doing
the math we have nearly 400,000 YouTube
subscribers right
which means that currently point 48
percent point 48 percent of our YouTube
audience are subscribers I'm sorry
patrons at patreon.com slash david
pakman show so that's that's a little
depressing but okay that's fine
we have slowed down though we had this
big influx of 1,900 patrons we've gotten
as high as close to 2000 and then it
just kind of leveled off so we have
added a new goal as the red arrow is
pointing to here the immediate goal on
patreon is 2,000 patrons and when we
reach that just kind of a funny little
thing I'll do an entire broadcast show
from the studio with my hair puffed up
and you might care about this you might
not it's not gonna change your life one
way or the other although maybe for some
people me doing a show with my hair like
this would be life-changing but my guess
is that's not going to be life changing
we have set up the next goal at 2500
patrons and you can read this for
yourself if you go to
patreon.com/scishow when we reach 2500
patrons we will produce a fully produce
the entire semester of college courses
and put them online now because we are
basing this around patreon we will first
make them available only to patrons
right so those 2500 patrons will get
access to those lectures first but I do
believe that a lot of what we're doing
on the program really is a public
service that's why we we pay for the
costs of distributing the show to 200
radio and TV stations so even though the
lectures will first be made available to
these 2,500 patrons or however many they
are when the lectures are finalized we
will then release them to everybody on
YouTube okay because I think that these
this material really deserves the widest
possible audience so this is a really
big thing this is what we're talking
about here is basically 15 to 20 hours
of long-form academic lectures on media
literacy and bias and filter bubbles and
echo chambers and critical thinking and
logical fallacies I mean this is I think
it's if we had more people studying this
stuff
I mean at scale we wouldn't have Donald
Trump as president of the United States
but at a you know more moderate modest
level we would just have a much more
informed electorate and that's a really
good thing so that's the big thing and
you can already make contributions and
I'll start doing thank-yous for anybody
who contributes during the livestream
at the end of the livestream by the way
if we have reached 1925 patrons which
isn't a big deal right if we get to 1925
I will also announce and create for you
a 55 percent membership discount code so
if we get to 1925 patrons there's gonna
be a discount code announced but the
goal is 2500 patrons and if and when we
do that and I believe we will because I
think that this is a really great thing
these long-form lectures 15 to 20 hours
of lectures will be made available from
my Boston College class on all of those
subjects that I mentioned okay before I
start doing thank-yous let's get back to
the let's get back to the questions and
we will do super chats first and then
stream labs then I'll do thank-yous and
we'll talk about some other stuff coming
up on the show jay w JH WH Goodall has
sent a 2 euro super chat two months ago
your stream had the same title that is
telling as I mentioned we should not
assume that this Trump Trump stuff is
going to end any time soon says e canal
as has sent a $20 super chat thank you
so much says he says he's saying merely
peace be with you and I appreciate those
sentiments thank you very much Tom
nickle Ison has sent a twenty Norwegian
kroner super chat with no question or
comment thank you very much I appreciate
it
JH WH Goodell sending a second a second
to euro super chat update updated my
pledge to $7 to make up for my expired
credit card I guess is what you mean
thank you very much very much appreciate
that saucy mix ah sir has sent a $10
super chat I'll admit that I'm not above
the YouTube drama
I thought your reply to sorry
video was lit fam you cooked him real
good just wondering if you've heard
anything back about having him on the
show okay so since since saucy brought
this up I will mention what's going on
sargon of akkad I know him as Karl
Benjamin you know but he uses the name
sargon of akkad on the internet he has a
YouTube channel and he did he first
accused me of having said that Joseph
Stalin was right-wing and then later did
a 30 minute video accusing me in the
context of that of Skype scapegoating
the right for anything that's bad and it
was a totally bogus sort of attempt at a
takedown and so we decided to put
together a rebuttal video and we did and
I'm actually I'm curious how that video
is doing and I thought it was a very
well put together video by the way
let's see Sargon I will just do a quick
search on our YouTube channel his video
got a ton of people contacting me saying
David how can you think that Stalin is
right-wing which of course I never said
so that video it's called sardonic odds
sargon of akkad takedown of David is
absurd it's got about 40,000 views in
the first couple of days the question
that saucy ask is if I wondering if I've
heard anything back about having him on
the show I haven't I mentioned during
the video I'm open to having him on the
program but not to debate semantic
labels like sjw [ __ ] and regressive or
whatever that I would have him on to
have a conversation about you know Tax
Policy or whatever I've not heard back
my understanding is that he's totally
banned from Twitter and so I don't know
exactly how I would hear from him he
would have to I guess email me or
something like that so that's the latest
James Fraser has sent a $5 super chat
I'm 18 and from Louisiana through my
experience even in the deep south the
social and economic message is somewhat
resonating with young voters here so
James I'm guessing you mean the
progressive social and economic message
that's good news that's good news
and I'd be interested to hear more from
you about in what ways you see that
message resonating in Louisiana but that
is absolutely good to hear the d2j bug
has sent a to Canadian dollar super chat
saying just insane in the membrane
insane in the brain yeah couldn't really
say it better myself
Felipe Garcia has sent the $2 super Chad
could the decision on gerrymandering
affect politics absolutely so at the top
level the issues that are sort of the
meta issues not mega but meta the
overarching issues that I I've
identified in politics right now are
gerrymandering campaign finance reform
and how elections are funded and more
broadly the way that our election system
works I believe we should have Instant
Runoff voting ranked choice voting and
that that would really allow third
parties to make inroads in a much more
serious way without people being
concerned about helping the other person
win by voting third party so yes we've
done a lot of long-form pieces on
gerrymandering and no doubt that that
would have a major major impact on
politics and ultimately really in terms
of so many different aspects of our day
to day discussions around politics if
you can change that status quo that
would make a huge huge difference okay
let's go over to stream lab stream Labs
comm slash the david pakman show is the
other place where you can make
contributions Kasper has sent a $5 and a
t-888 cent stream labs comment asking am
I worried about the advent of artificial
intelligence you know I've done a few
interviews on artificial intelligence
and I know that NAT now there are
increasingly it's increasingly popular
to retweet or to try to signal boost
some of the artificial intelligence
alarmists and I'm trying to remember I
think that I don't remember if Stephen
Hawking is an alarmist or an ant
alarmist on artificial intelligence I
believe Elon Musk of SpaceX and Tesla
Fame is an artificial intelligence
alarmist in the sense of it could really
backfire and be bad you know I'm not
that worried about it that's just where
I am and maybe it's because the the
people I've interviewed on it have sort
of rationally explained why the alarmist
fears around artificial intelligence are
seemingly a concern but why we don't
actually have to be as worried about
those concerns as some would make it
seem so maybe I don't know enough about
it to be alarmed right if you ignorant
is bliss to a certain degree but I my
instinct is I've done enough interviews
and and reading about artificial
intelligence that I would be more
alarmed if there really was as much to
be alarmed about and maybe people will
disagree and if you do feel free to let
me know in Super chatter or stream labs
purple haze oh nine has sent a $5 stream
Labs contribution hey David I wanted to
know your general opinions on the
concepts of the left and the right the
major two-party system do you think that
the constant reference to the
us-versus-them mentality is more
divisive than unifying well this is you
know here's the problem there's no doubt
that many elements of the stat political
status quo are more divisive than
unifying gerrymandering is one of them
the fact that we don't have rank choice
voting is one of them because people
effectively end up taking one side or
the other within the two-party system
because they feel like favoring someone
else supporting someone else will either
help the candidate they really don't
like win or just be meaningless so rank
choice voting so yes I do believe that
the status quo furthers division rather
than unification but it's become very
popular to make these overarching
generalizations like we need to stop the
divisive politics and bring the country
together really well propose a policy
that would do that because almost always
the people who say that then will will
suggest some extreme
namely partisan solution quote solution
to an issue which will not bring anybody
together right
the truth is somewhere in the middle no
it's not it's not that it's not always
true and it's not necessarily true
very often the truth is not in the
middle climate change is the truth in
the middle there's 97% consensus on what
humans are doing to the climate the
other 3% is filled with flawed science
has recently revealed by a meta-analysis
that I told you about so where is the
middle where is the middle on that so I
think that it is true that we have a
system that fundamentally pushes
divisive nathanael but I think merely
pointing that out and making these broad
generalizations that people like to make
about oh let's let's let's work more
collaborative collaborative laborat of
lis etc are often also quite full of hot
air
Cristina has sent a dollar contribution
through stream labs comm / the David
Pakman show do you decorate for
Halloween will you be or do you usually
dress up or celebrate Halloween no no
absolutely not I do not do any Halloween
decoration I will sometimes being in the
Northeast and get a pumpkin and I will
not typically carve the pumpkin I'll
sometimes carve a pumpkin with my little
sister but I will usually make something
with pumpkin so like a couple years ago
I made a huge pumpkin cheesecake that
was my fall / Halloween contribution
I rarely dress up I just find it
annoying I feel like I'm over it you
know I'm too old for that and I know
you're never too old to dress up blah
blah blah if I'm invited to an actual
Halloween party I will wear a costume I
won't do that thing where I show up with
no costume but it's usually like a wig
and sunglasses or something sort of
random like that and I will not I've not
lived anywhere for a long time where
there are trick-or-treaters so I never
even have candy to give out because I've
lived in apartment buildings or condos
for a really long time so yeah not
boring sad but that's the truth okay I
announced earlier during the livestream
that we are starting a new initiative
where once we reach 2500 page
contributors we will be producing 15 to
20 hours of my Boston College lectures
and making those available online the
target is 2500 donors this is very
egalitarian because each donor doesn't
matter how much you contribute counts
once it doesn't matter what you donate
we are trying to get to 2500 patrons and
a few people that I do want to thank who
have made new or increased their
contributions during the livestream
Shaun Egan has made a pledge of $1 a
month
thank you very much Kirsten Judd has
edited their pledge from five to seven
dollars per month
thank you and Max kee has pledged two
dollars per month at patreon.com slash
david pakman show please get those
contributions in as I mentioned if we
get to 1925 patrons before the end of
the stream and it can't be a super long
stream tonight I've actually got a
travel day tomorrow and I'll talk a
little bit about what's going on if you
can if we can get to 1925 and we're 13
away right now I will create a 55%
membership discount code and announce it
to you during the live stream now that's
not the only way to support we do also
have membership this is the number one
funding source for the program if you
sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership you can use the coupon code
as you see here I voted 17 that'll save
you 40% still get a hundred percent of
the benefits I do want to thank Andrew
Casa Nidhi who has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership as well as
Florrie Giffen tersh ax
watson and tatiana McGinnis thanks to
all of you for signing up at david
pakman.com slash membership you all get
instant access to the world-famous bonus
show the bonus show is huge the bonus
show is major so that is uh that's a
thing all right let's get to some of the
other questions that have come up we're
all questions are welcome both through
super chat and through stream labs.com
slash the david pakman show JH WH
Goodall has sent a 5 euro super chat
difficult question does the idea of
American exceptionalism and overboard
patriotism prevent a rational debate on
how to learn from other countries
absolutely absolutely I know so many
people who I don't associate with too
much anymore because I'm just done with
it I feel like I'm too old to surround
myself with people who I find have just
toxic and destructive political views I
agree that very often I will mention
something about oh you've never been to
Europe you've got to go to Europe it's
you know it's a whole different
lifestyle to hold different culture and
the five o'clock drink and the
relationship to work is different in
vacation time and family yeah they're
just so lazy over there I mean these you
here in France they work in 20 28 32
hours a week now or whatever you're
absolutely right it is the the overboard
hyper page pseudo patriotism they call
it patriotism is really a conversation
stopper the preaching show has sent a $2
super chat if net neutrality goes what
can people do well I would encourage
people to get involved before it goes
because if it goes your ability to do
things about it could potentially be
limited by virtue of net neutrality
going okay
so I don't I don't know I actually don't
have sort of an action plan if net
neutrality goes but it may go there are
many people who are trying to get it to
go at this point and I I mean it's it's
bad it's bad
and I wish I had some kind of solution
tomaso Pinkerton has sent a three dollar
and fifty cent contribution contribution
via super chat no question or comment
thanks very much tomaso appreciate it
and then over at stream labs.com slash
the david pakman show i've received a
dollar contribution from purple haze oh
nine who says PS had a new job interview
today hopefully a pay raise will allow
me to a to afford a regular subscription
fingers crossed well good luck and I
hope you do get the job purple haze
regardless of whether you increase your
contribution to the
and yeah I've said this before I've
actually said this many times I do I
don't do the show with the idea that I
need every person who watches or listens
contributing financially in fact as I
mentioned we have a fraction of 1% of
our YouTube audience that contributes
financially through through stream labs
super chat patreon or membership but I
do think it's important and I do this in
my personal life if you do have the
means I think it is important to
contribute to independent media that you
value because since not everybody can
the people who can contribute are
subsidizing alternative viewpoints and
independent media outlets for everybody
right so the good is it's sort of a
shared good it's a not a socialist ideal
but a social democracy ideal which is
that those of us who are able to make
any contribution even if a dollar or two
a month to programs like ours and it
doesn't have to be ours you're doing
something good for everybody right and I
think that that is a really important
thing and on that note I do want to send
another thank you to Travis James Heath
who has pledged five dollars a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show i
announced earlier that when we get to
2500 patrons we will be creating
producing and releasing 15 to 20 hours
of long-form lectures from the class
I've been teaching at Boston College
including such subject matter as
critical thinking epistemology
media literacy biases logical fallacies
echo chambers and filter bubbles if that
is interesting to you make a
contribution of any amount that is
comfortable to you even as little as a
dollar a month counts towards what we
are trying to build here so I encourage
you to do that and more thank yous
forthcoming okay let me take a scan
through the non-super chat youtube
discussions because i want to answer
other people's questions as well even if
people aren't contributing to the show
one person saying dude you talk to
much it's a live stream you know what
happens when I don't talk yeah it gets
really weird like what are we doing just
watching me sit at a computer and
microphone that's really really weird
let's see what else do we have here in
Luxembourg we only have 25 days of
holiday if you're talking about 25
working days that is way more than the
average worker gets in the United States
that is five paid weeks of vacation and
most people don't get that here in the
United States do you think Russia is
using YouTube to do propaganda like a
che Goodman's channel I have no idea
what a J Goodman's funding sources are I
couldn't speak to that but I think that
it you know Russia has been using
Twitter and has been using Facebook it
would be weird if Russia wasn't also
using YouTube to some degree a lot of
people talking about the entire sargon
of akkad
debate not much that I have to say about
that let's see what do I think will
bring Trump down obstruction or money
laundering you know from from what I've
been seeing from Robert Muller the
hiring of attorneys who are well versed
in financial related crimes financial
crimes and the types of questions that
seem to be asked of people involved I
think that the financial side of it
potentially has more potential to bring
Trump down obstruction of justice is
pretty difficult to prove not as
difficult as you know employment
discrimination but I think that it is a
that that is potentially the way to go
let's see what else we've had have here
maybe one day David Pakman would do an
interview with Christian pitch aleni
I don't know who that is but sure I'd be
open to checking that out some of the
questions and comments from the general
chat always good to see what people are
saying actual justice warrior has sent
the twenty dollar super chat should we
ignore all trite trolls to protest
statues of a jewish confederate named
Judah Benjamin vice to Prez Jay Davis I
don't know what that means
they say Jews fought for South had
higher
percentage of slaves very involved in
the white and black slave trade I'm not
sure what the question is should we
ignore all right troll to protest statue
of a jewish confederate named Judah
Benjamin vice to president Jay Davis oh
okay I see what you're saying I still
don't know what the question is but I
I'm sorry I'm just not if somebody can
maybe restate that but I'm just I'm
doing my best I can't understand that
the preaching show has sent a $2 super
chat what could be done if the sinclair
merger happens move your dollars to
independent media I don't know what else
to say that that's I'm sort of at a loss
there Paul treadle wits has sent the $2
super chat saying just thanks well thank
you for the contribution Paul appreciate
it
Travis the human has sent a $5 super
Chad I just found out that Diane Russell
will be running for governor of Maine
she supported Bernie and helped legal
marijuana here she is not LePage I did
not know that Diane Russell Maine
governor that's interesting I've been
making an effort to really talk to the
audience about races that you can get
involved in because that it's just what
we have to do
it's just what we what we have to do and
that is a good news and we will talk
about that debark Oh for $2 super check
where did you imp at meat grinder
grinder of course a gay dating app which
doesn't make a lot of sense since
neither Pat or I are gay but yes we did
meet on grinder even though we're both
heterosexual no I met Pat because Pat
started as an intern with the David
Pakman show
very clever question though very very
clever question on stream labs.com slash
the David Pakman show
let's see who do we have here
ironic cat has sent a $2.00 stream Labs
contribution just got off the phone with
a Republican politician he spoke
lovingly
his support of populist ideals and then
pivots to put Trump on his fetish
pedestal for the supposed populist
platform how do we cut through the haze
and unite about the issues if I knew the
answer to that I would have already told
you but I would encourage you to check
out the interview I did some time ago
with Federico Finkelstein a fellow
Argentinean about populism is not one
thing right you have left wing populism
and you have right wing populism and
Donald Trump has populist rhetoric but
really it's all under the guise of a
more authoritarian right wing type of
populism and listen since he's become
president what populist thing says
Donald Trump actually done hard to hard
to really name any let's do some thank
yous I mentioned that once we reach
2,500 patreon contributors I am going to
with our team produce and create 15 to
20 hours of long-form lectures based on
the material from my Boston College
course okay when we get to 2500 patrons
the goal for this evening is 1925
patrons and we're making headway Luc
Barnard has made a pledge of $5 a month
Rafael de la Torre has made a pledge of
$2 a month
and Ethan Andrade Andre I don't know how
to pronounce that last name has pledged
$5 per month that puts us at 1916
patrons right now if we get just nine
more nine more if we get to 1925 I will
create and release a 55 percent discount
code for membership and then anybody who
wants a 55 percent off membership can
sign up for it but it'll be our little
secret I won't announce it anywhere else
just 9 more patrons and we will do that
and I think that that will be that will
be exciting for a lot of people Paul
Tribble wits has sent a $2 super chat
following up just for saying the name
perfectly pronounced Paul Tribble wits
yeah
I don't know how else you would
pronounce that Paul if people have been
mispronouncing that I would love to know
more about that because it's not making
a lot of sense to me I don't know how
how somebody could could mispronounce a
name so obvious as trivets
okay so let me talk a little bit about
what is upcoming on the David Pakman
show
we are off on Friday so Monday is the
federal holiday Columbus Day it's a
horrible federal holiday in the sense
that it really whitewashes some really
horrible history of the United States
but it is a federal holiday and because
I believe that it is important to do
more than just what is the common thing
in the United States of you know you get
six vacation days or ten vacation days
we try to actually provide a vacation so
so staff can take time off so we are off
on Monday and we are piggybacking on the
three-day weekend particularly because I
have to travel to a wedding in Arizona
by also taking Friday off so no new show
on Friday no new show on Monday and thus
tomorrow's show the Thursday show is
going to be like a Friday show in the
sense that we will be doing a classic
interview we will be taking live phone
calls we will be answering audience
questions so for people who are not just
YouTube subscribers but also are
watching on TV or DirecTV or listening
on the radio or listening to the full
podcast tomorrow's program will might be
confusing because it will be like a
Friday show even though it won't
actually be Friday then
now I want to just I'm gonna pitch
something I don't know if this is going
to happen tomorrow I fly to Arizona for
this wedding and former producer Louis
is also going to be at that wedding and
I am getting picked up at the airport
by producer Louis and another friend or
two of ours so what if during the drive
to where the wedding is going to be I
streamed live from the car and
interviewed former producer Louis about
what he is up to it is unpredictable
what sort of internet connection I would
have it is unpredictable
whether Lewis would even have anything
to say but is that something that would
be interesting to people because I think
it might be interesting to figure out
what it is that producer Lewis has been
up to so I'm just going to pitch that
and maybe you know what if we get to the
1925 patreon contributors tonight then I
will really make an effort to get that
done technology and internet connection
allowing tomorrow okay so so 1925
patrons will get us a 55% membership
discount code and I will attempt to
interview Lewis live tomorrow and that
would probably be around around 5:00 or
6:00 Eastern Time I think so yeah that
is something to think about if that's
interesting let's get those patreon
contributions in okay
JH WH Goodell has sent another super
chat for two euros saying I listened to
your show during the more during morning
work love it well thank you thank you
very much the preaching show with a two
dollar super chat what do you think the
is that future of LGBTQ rights well
worldwide we need to see more
legalization of same-sex marriage in the
United States and worldwide we need to
see a sexual orientation added as a
protected class right in a lot of states
in the United States you can still be
fired for your sexual orientation even
though you're allowed to marry whoever
you want in all 50 states at this point
you can still be fired for your your
actual or perceived which is an
important part of it
sexual orientation so I think in the
United States that's the next front on
LGBT rights
Jamal Swift sent a ten dollar super Chad
I'm just tuning in so sorry if you
talked about this topic before how do
you think the Catalonian independence
will affect the European Union I don't
know I'm not actually sure I'm talking
to you I've got a lot of contacts in
Spain because my dad's wife is in Spain
so I've got quite a bit of family there
and even some of my Argentinian
there's one little wing of it that lives
in Spain so I'm in touch with them and I
I'm trying to figure that out myself
Jamal I mean I think there's no question
that it will affect the European Union
it will probably also bolster other
independence type movements and that's
something else to consider but I will I
will follow up on that we've been
talking about that what's going on in in
Catalonia a little bit and I will follow
up with you on that probably when we're
back Chad Curtis with a $5 super chat
for providing well made logical and
unbiased content well thanks very much
Chad appreciate that James Fraser with a
$5 super chat how do you think Democrats
can appeal to southern voters I know
people here and there are some
progressive agreement if you poke enough
love to talk more yeah so I think you
know it's different on every issue right
but I've been talking about this for
some time I think the general approach
the general approach to appealing to
southern voters to conservative voters
whatever it needs to be different than
how we appeal to left-wing voters so for
example with climate change the way to
appeal to the left is you just explain
hey here's the scientific consensus it's
it's not good what we're doing let's do
something else that's it right the left
gets it the right not so much so I think
the right you need to use arguments more
along if you can find a morality
argument like what we are doing is
immoral to the to the planet and it's
immoral to future generations or
whatever national security fiscal
conservatism I don't know I mean I think
you have to analyze it issue by issue
but it's a toe it has to be a totally
different approach beating beating
southern voters with facts over the head
is not going to make them vote for
Bernie all of a sudden the preaching
show has sent a $2 super chat if net
neutrality goes could it be reinstated
absolutely
oh absolutely I mean there could be
damage done that you can't undo right I
mean during the time that net neutrality
could be eliminated damage can be done
that is not undoable but it can of
course be reinstated in the future okay
christina has sent a dollar stream labs
contribution at stream labs calm / the
David Pakman show
yes I miss Lewis so much that is a vote
in favor of a live interview with
producer Louis tomorrow from from
Arizona all right a lander I'll lander
not sure how to pronounce that has sent
a $2.00 stream Labs contribution love
your show greetings from Helsinki
Finland very much interested in visiting
Helsinki I mean I've been hearing about
this trip that people like doing now
where you fly into Helsinki and you do
some tourism there and then you take a
ferry a boat of some kind to Estonia and
that Estonia apparently is still sort of
an under visited gem of Europe that has
not become overrun with tourists and
that that's interesting to me but you
know the Helsinki is cold a lot of the
year so you've got to pick the right
time Casper has sent a $5 and 88 cent
stream Labs contribution if you get
completely desensitized and cynical you
can always rename the show to be
whatever the case may be show yeah right
if I stop caring about the outcome of
American politics
I can I can just say hey whatever is
fine it'll kind of even out in the end
let me say thank you to a new member at
david pakman.com slash membership Linda
Carter Altman has signed up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership thank you so much I really
really appreciate it and every new
member everybody who signs up everybody
who makes a patreon pledge everybody is
helping to sort of chip away I guess is
way I would consider it at this which is
just the absolutely horrific and
horrible eighty-five percent revenue hit
that we have taken as a result of the
YouTube advertiser boycott really really
not good stuff
JH whe adult thank you for the 10 euro
contribution is the livestream the right
way to get new patrons only 306 people
watching I'm watching because I got the
message but I'm already a member how
many people watch this who are not
already involved yet you know we've had
a long phase where the live streams had
between one and four thousand concurrent
live viewers and that was just blowing
up patreon but the truth is we're in a
period right now where the the live
streams are just not getting as many
viewers and part of it is I might be
using less hyperbolic titles times of
day are a factor and just generally you
know I've been talking to a lot of other
youtubers and we're all sort of
experiencing slower growth than we were
in the six months right after Donald
Trump was elects elected so yeah I mean
there's no we we take an
all-of-the-above approach but what I
will say is I am there I'm always I am
perpetually interested in new ideas from
the audience about how to continue
growing the financial base of support
from the probe for the program because
why would I limit myself if we can if
there are other ways that we could be
talking about patreon or whatever else
by all means let's let's do it stream
labs comm slash the david pakman show
Christina sending a dollar contribution
when was the last time you were
disappointed by something you had been
previously excited about uh I don't
there's a lot of little examples I mean
I remember for example I was I'm I know
very I knew very little about London
when I visited last December and one of
the things that I plan to do while there
was visit Shakespeare's Globe Theatre
and I thought it was actually a really
old theatre and upon arrival I found out
that it was a brand-new recreation of a
really old Shakespearean theatre so that
kind of bummed
I was disappointed by the last season of
house of cards I thought it was good but
not as good as it could have been I was
disappointed by a recent hotel that I
stayed and I don't know I my
disappointments are pretty boring no
incredibly exciting disappointments Chad
Curtis has sent a $2.00 super Chad
banning high-capacity magazines and bump
stops effective or no you know there's
two views on this one view is people who
are determined that the the pro-gun
right will say people who are determined
to commit crimes with guns will figure
out a way to do it and they will just
obtain what they want illegally the
counter to that is yes any individual
person if determined enough can find
what they need to do the damage they
want to do but by making some of these
items more difficult to come by because
you are making them illegal you're
reducing the number that are sort of
floating around illegally even on the
black market so I think that there is
something to it but it is not a be-all
it's not a panacea when it comes to
solving the problem that we have in the
United States with gun crime and as a
result you know you every any time
someone says hey Australia did X let's
do that or Switzerland does Y let's do
that or Mexico has this situation and
yet they still have major problems with
guns the problem is no situation is like
another the situation with guns is the
situation with guns in the United States
in a country with the level of gun
ownership that we have in a country with
the contingent that is ideologically and
almost in a way that's dogmatically
religious attached to their firearms so
yeah it in in the same ways that what
has not worked for other countries might
actually work for us things that have
worked in other countries might not work
for us and I don't think that there is a
sort of one-size-fits-all solution to
the gun problem in American culture is
is a big part of that a lander has sent
a $2.00 stream Labs contribution saying
you pronounce my name correctly Thanks
yes very cold in Finland
that's what I've read on the internet
that is what I have read on the Internet
and on that note I am going to wrap up
today's livestream after one more I
believe we have one more super chat that
just came in and I don't want to miss
that it was a $5 or maybe that was
stream Labs let me see here yes Trevor
you win one with a $5 contribution love
your show from Canada Thank You Love
Canada was recently in Montreal hope to
get back there soon and on that note
that's it I will see about interviewing
Luis on the live stream tomorrow from
Arizona if my flight makes it there on
time and everything goes as planned